[Music]
welcome back
i'm steve brunton and this is a new
lecture series on
sparsity and compression this is chapter
three from our new book data driven
science and engineering
so many of you have seen in spy movies
james bond jason bourne
some satellite photograph taken from you
know miles up
of a credit card or a license plate
that is blurry but through some kind of
magic software
they're able to refine uh kind of the
letters and the information
to to get you know a legible credit card
number
or license plate don't worry this is
just my japanese metro card
so that's what we're going to be talking
about we're going to go you know into
the mathematics
of how you would take low fidelity
signals
and try to pull out as much information
as possible to kind of refine or get
super resolution
images that's one application or to
you know maybe someone is trying to
disguise themselves with a fake mustache
and big glasses can we subtract those
off of their face and figure out what's
underneath that image so that's all kind
of applications that we're going to be
able to explore
in this context of sparsity and
compression and so much more we're going
to use this for
modeling complex systems reduced order
modeling
robustifying our dimensionality
reduction and machine learning
algorithms
uh it's the basis of of all of image
compression which we saw a little bit
uh in the last chapter on the the fast
fourier transform
okay so i'm really excited this is going
to be
one of my favorite this is one of my
favorite chapters of the book
it's one of my favorite topics in
general and there's a lot of really
really exciting
new research coming out in this this
area of sparsity
and compression and compressed sensing
uh every week there's new and
interesting results
okay so we've already seen uh kind of
this diagram of how
compression in general works image
compression so you start with a high
resolution image
in this case of this jellyfish and in
uh some transformed basis in this case
in the fast fourier transform or wavelet
basis one of those bases
then most of the fourier coefficients
are very very small
this is actually plotted in a log plot
so so most of these are almost
zero and you can truncate and throw away
the vast majority of those
of those entries maybe 95 percent 99
or even more can be thrown away or
truncated
so you only keep very few fourier
coefficients that are actually
contributing
to the information in this image and
then when you inverse fourier transform
you recover
a very high fidelity representation of
your original image
okay so this is kind of the the starting
point for this new lecture
series on sparsity and compression is
where we left off uh with the fourier
transform and wavelet transforms
okay and i just want to point out kind
of almost definitionally what do we mean
by sparse
so up here this image of the jellyfish
is what i'm going to call dense because
you need all of those pixels if you
threw away 95
of these jellyfish pixels it wouldn't
look like much
okay but in this representation after we
transform it through this unitary
fourier
transform into a new coordinate system
now what we have
is a sparse representation of our
original data
and actually it's it's especially sparse
down here once i've manually thrown away
the 95 smallest fourier coefficients
and so really what i mean down here is
sparse what that kind of means
is mostly zero entries
okay so that's what i mean by sparse
it's a it's a vector
or an array or you know generally a
tensor whatever it's a mathematical
object usually a vector or an array
that mostly contains zero entries that's
what we mean by sparse
is that you can throw away most of the
information and there's only a few
entries that are non-zero in this case
these kind of core
fourier frequencies in the middle that
you need to reconstruct the image
so that's the idea of compression we've
already talked a lot about this with
respect to the fourier transform wavelet
transform
but now we're going to turn this whole
paradigm up on its end and start asking
more fundamental questions why
are signals so compressible so that's
that's maybe the first and most
fundamental
is why um are signals so compressible
okay and this is actually one of my
favorite uh
kind of areas of applied math is really
digging into
kind of why signals have so much
structure why is it
that you know even though i collected a
million pixels here i only need five
percent of that information in this
representation that's a really
interesting and fundamental question
we're going to we're going to answer
another one is
if i if i know that i'm going to collect
this million pixels just to throw away
95 or 99 of them after compression
did i need to collect all of those
measurements in the first place
so that's really a huge question can
we measure less
this is a really really interesting
question can i get away with measuring
you know five or ten percent of those
pixels maybe at random
and can i infer what these sparse
fourier coefficients these active
fourier coefficients have to be to be
consistent with those measurements can i
down sample
and still reconstruct my high resolution
image now if you asked this question
20 years ago the answer would be no you
can't but advances in applied math in
the last few decades have made this
possible
so there's a huge field called
compressed sensing
compressed sensing
and this promises to revolutionize how
we collect data and how we do signal
processing in some
applications okay so this could
this could change data acquisition
acquisition it's always dangerous
spelling live
data acquisition okay so compress
sensing is super interesting can we get
away with measuring less do we have to
measure all of these million pixels if
we know we're going to throw away most
of them
anyway we're going to talk about some
fundamental mathematical concepts like
the l1 and the l2 norm so we're going to
explore
uh kind of the math and the norms the
math
of norms and in particular we're going
to look at the l1 and l2 norms
okay so you're used to the l2 norm
which is kind of given by these circles
of equal radius in the l2 norm
but the l1 norm you have
looking like diamonds okay so
kind of points of equal radius in the l1
norm
look like diamonds uh versus the circles
you're used to
okay and it turns out that this l1 norm
is really really important in finding
solutions that are sparse and promoting
sparsity so we're going to look at the
l1 norm
and why it is so useful for kind of
compressed sensing
and ensuring sparsity in signals okay
and one of the things that i really love
about this field is that it is extremely
practical what you can do once you
understand sparsity and compression
and kind of the geometry of these high
dimensional vectors and objects and
signals
is that you can develop robust
algorithms so you can have
kind of your favorite algorithms from
before
so all of the algorithms you know and
love you can robustify them
to outliers or corrupt data or missing
data all kinds of things you can
robustify your favorite algorithms
again using sparsity and the l1 norm and
things we're going to talk about in this
lecture series
so neural networks that's a big one the
singular value decomposition
and pca so we're going to robustify the
principal components analysis that's a
huge one
reduced order models what we're going to
call roms reduced order models
of physical systems we're going to use
sparsity to get
interpretable models for physical
systems
and we can also use this for sensor
placement
so if you only had a limited budget of
sensors let's say you want to drop buoys
in the ocean
where would you put them to maximally
measure some system
well something about the sparse
structure of that system can inform
sensor placement as well
okay so all of this is going to be
related to
tools in linear algebra optimization and
statistics so so everything we're going
to talk about here
is fundamentally rooted in linear
algebra and optimization
and a lot of these robust algorithms you
can think of in a statistical context
okay so that's where we're going with
this
i'm super excited this is one of my
absolute favorite topics
i think this is going to be a great
lecture series chapter three of our book
data driven science and engineering and
again if you like this
this video in this series please like
please subscribe please comment below
and stay tuned because we're going to
have a bunch we're going to answer all
these questions
thank you